on this episode we talk about louis c.k
we talk about any selling paintings and
we talk about law
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk in a
SEPA sewed and this is episode 123 one
two three of the ask gary vee show a
little flub there on the intro that's a
rare there'll be a quiz question kind of
a trivia question in the future
solid mood today because I finally India
I finally have by the way I fully expect
your entire know your mom and dad are
starting to watch a show here and there
I fully expect them to buy this t-shirt
I fully expect all people that are
hardcore India fans to buy the let's get
into the show t-shirt d-roc link it up
and there it is and for 72 hours it's 14
bucks bones as they used to say on Wine
Library TV and so I'm super excited
about that let's link that up also in
YouTube and so I'm really excited about
this t-shirt India do you feel like this
is a big moment in your career to have a
t-shirt that is so associated with your
brilliance uh
absolutely not or a huge okay good good
not well IIIi guess with that with that
India uh let's get into the show show
yeah sure
I know you guys like it peanut gallery
likes it yes Sid the intern show uh-huh
age I heard it your age I got confused
cuz you you thought mark yog it was in
here you thought mark Yod kidding listen
here no I told you I came I mean
DeMaio has never booked another show in
here God sorry AJ hey he's running
serious business and we're kind of
goofing around here on the show uh
really excited about one two three so
after a good start so India let's do
this Sammy asks we both share an
affinity for pickup hoops and social
media what if any similarities do you
see in these two passion points all
rights to rock the rock drop those
headphones
um you better be Grady Rock know it
we're fired
pick-up hoops and social media um I I
think here's the one correlation that
comes to mind I think a good one I think
that it's super interesting in the fact
that when you play pick-up hoops you
actually don't know who's gonna be on
your team
right usually ten characters get around
ten twelve characters you shoot some
free throws the five on five you look at
the dynamics and very quickly within the
first five to ten 15 minutes or if it
lasts that long definitely through the
first five or ten possessions you're
trying to figure out the dynamics of a
team work on the team on the spot
I find that myself very similar going
through that kind of motion when I'm
trying to learn vine or snapchat or
periscope or meerkat and old school
Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
Instagram those first days right like
something's popped like everybody's
talking about I remember meerkat this
just happened you know six months ago
all of a sudden on a weekend everybody's
talking and obviously I'm in a nice
brand position where everyone's like
one's garyvee gonna be on meerkat wins
big area
you know beam right now right like
you're figuring out your way of doing it
on that platform and that to me it
really does remind me of a pickup
basketball where you're trying to figure
out the dynamics of the game similarly
to early days in social media apps that
was really good let's just look I know
we're great right now but like I'm black
and white but like maybe that was a
really really good answer to to a very
difficult question I don't like how you
threw me a curveball there to start the
show I thought it was like an
interesting question I thought I was not
is that easy that could have been kind
of on those sillies like don't bring any
value to the audience kind of thing like
hahaha likes stuff on stinks I've asked
well like you know like laughs like but
I feel great I'm clearly in tremendous
form as we are in the 120s I think I'm
really hitting an all-time there's a
dark-horse chance that the episode in
the 120s you know 120 to 129 will be
considered a great era of the askgaryvee
show
would you buy the one you know I'm a
huge fan of 120 to 129 askgaryvee show
t-shirt one day okay good
the amount of shirts that I'm planning
on Scott asks louis c.k doesn't take
selfies with fans instead he shakes
their hands and talks to them with 2015
Miss Manners approved so first and
foremost it's not my place to judge and
anything so just stay on there India uh
it's not my place to judge Louis CK's
execution how he interacts with his fans
I think you know there are very few
things that I hold up to a pedestal more
than one's interaction with their fan
base whether that's eight people or a
trillion people I you know there's one
thing that's interesting to me in this
is you know my first gut reaction I'm
that's not true I'm so damn curious if
he desperately like a religion believes
that's the right interaction or if he's
just sticking a little bit to make a
point it got asked on this show is it a
thing is it a fight the system kind of
play from him I don't know much about
this so I'm going on question right
there you see something what's going on
here why he doesn't take photo so I need
to check that out I'm super interesting
I can tell you that you're reading it
really quick uh you know what's the gist
India right so I listen that's his
prerogative I do believe that if you're
lucky enough to make millions of [ __ ]
dollars to be in the limelight that
there are certain things that you should
I think if a fan wants the selfie that
you should deliver on that but that's
just one humble man's point of view I
have tons of empathy if you're
introverted or you don't like it but to
me the the fan is always right that a
fan wants a signed book if they want to
picture if they want a handshake if they
just want to thank me if they want me if
they want to give me their book I'm just
very thankful they want to do anything
and so for me I'm most comfortable in
counterpunching reverse-engineering the
finish line for the other person but I
can't be mad at somebody drawing lines
because I mean you may be a germaphobe
like oh but he said shake hands you know
everybody's got their own thing I see a
lot of people who are actually very
scared of germs that don't want to shake
up
hands and it's awkward like you know
there's all sorts of things out there so
for me I think it's a Mis play I think
more and more people are going to want
to do it
I think it means so much more to them
you know if you're a celebrity of his
value I'm sure he has empathy to
recognize that people want to show off
that picture and put under social it's
such a it's like not the event it's the
aftermath of the event and so I want to
provide that for people that value that
and I'm humbled that anybody would want
to do that with me and I'm sure there's
a lot of people that weren't able to
take a selfie that are massively
disappointed in that interaction but I
respect people creating their own
personal boundaries people are different
than businesses to me I can get really
mad at businesses because there's people
driving that logo but as a human people
have their lines in the sand
thanks Enya Matthew now Andy you were
saying Matthew is super greedy for
trying to be on the show well I know
that you don't want to be awkward when
he gets you Friday because you guys are
now harsh atomies because of this
statement I'm kidding I'm kidding
Matthew India and I both agree more me
than India I just wanted to create an
awkward scene that you already won I'm
seeing you Friday and here you are
trying to Jack someone's question with
another question of your own that being
said I'm the one that sent it to you
because I thought it was really good so
good job on hacking here it is Gary
Matthew Chamber yes the very same
Matthew chain was one of the winners of
the crew for a day challenge thank you
so much for choosing me as you can see
I'm resting up for the big day but
before that Gary I have a question put
yourself in my shoes you just want to
trip to me Gary Vaynerchuk I mean you're
pumped right like you've involved this
dude for a while and this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity for you how would
you go about preparing yourself for that
type of trip would you you know set
expectations and goals are just kind of
go with the flow what would you do if
you were meeting you you keep throwing
contests
I'll keep winning them that's pretty odd
I listen I like that that's problem by
the way that last part is probably why
this questions on the show
I like the bravado um respectful bravado
is very attractive bravado and sanity is
not there's a little forewarning to some
of the people's actions in last couple
of weeks um I think that uh I think that
uh what I would do is I would probably
bring him some English peas because I
would know that Gary loves English
peas and not like the [ __ ] kind like
the big ones like the snap like you know
like English peas not like Long Island
English peas which are a little smaller
definitely not snow peas like sugar peas
or English so many different names I
mean every [ __ ] every everything
yeah the way exactly 118 watch those the
big ones so I would bring him that I'd
probably bring him like a rare Jets
Jersey of maybe the second or third
round pick in the draft this year I want
else do I want
I would probably bring some cool Nikes
you know like something that was like
fly like these like you know that would
you know I would drive it bribe him and
to thank you know I you know the answers
of question is very simple is you know
the second you start I think you've
already lost
I predict that your Friday experience is
not gonna be as good as you think
because you're already overthinking it
you need to roll in bu the end the end
the end it works for me so much
yesterday Brandon Marshall is here right
football player Jets wide receiver arms
I don't even know how to not be myself
first of all I think I'm better than
everybody so I don't get starstruck it's
a flaw and a strength and and I think
you roll in with that thing I think you
walk in and you just need to be
basically as it's so hard and I get it I
mean really around jet players is
probably where I struggle with it the
most biggest I crushed it
just you have to be yourself there's
nothing else because because then if it
doesn't then by the way this is why
fundamentally believe in being yourself
this is the secret reason to being
yourself if you're not yourself and then
it doesn't go well you have to think
about that for the rest of your life you
like went out of your way to not let the
natural thing happen and it didn't go
well that sucks I'd much rather be like
well you know when I get a comment that
like you suck or right now the the USC
video and the Monday motivation video
are both going viral on Facebook right a
lot of people never see me before when
somebody says you suck I'm like well
that was my that was me like that's just
where the chips fell but to like if that
was my stick or if that was a fake
version me or that well then that would
hurt be like well what if I just was me
right and so that my friends is why it's
always best because then you don't have
to second-guess
I wanted to be an animated gif I know I
never sneeze that was super rare I'm
telling you guys episode 1 - I'm telling
you episode 122 episode 129 is gonna
have some of the great rarities
something to see all-time great moments
in the show's history he's always
talking about you what's up what's up
talking about you oh my god you know
what's so weird about that in a Russian
Jewish superstition in my family oh my
god I would say a lot of Russians watch
a site watch nut which means exactly in
our thing our superstition is if you
sneeze whatever you said last is true
which means that was one which means
that was one of the truest statements in
one in my most of Wine Library in
askgaryvee episode history and it
happened between Episode one 2129 India
I'm just telling you guys this is the
golden era you know like wrestling has a
golden e'er like sport like this is
gonna be the golden era I mean I can
feel it these episodes are yes really
guys I don't know if you read the
comments if you're in it as hard as I am
like many people thought yesterday was
the best episode of all time and that's
coming off the back of everybody said
clearly emotionally being most into 118
with me my dad I got emotional into
death but yeah I mean I brought it
yesterday today there's a different kind
of energy a little bit more entertaining
but not too you know the first answer
was super on point India let's keep this
going
Derrick asks what's your top tip for a
creative mind to start thinking like an
entrepreneur
dude this is this is a tough one right
there's so many creatives that just
don't know how to be a salesperson
entrepreneurial they don't have that
gear they have incredible creative chops
first and foremost I want to be very
careful to try to mold you with tactics
that you have no chance of winning at
that's like me saying like how do I want
to start being a great painter well I
can go watch YouTube videos to like be
better at paint I can go buy some good
paint I could start painting but I'm
funny feeling if I like showed it to
India she'd be polite because she's a
wonderful human being but with her
artistic eyes you know
yeah no Gary really like I could see
some stuff they're like yeah I'm like
[ __ ] she hates it like so to me I'm very
concerned of forcing people just because
you may be excited about what
putting out there what society is
pushing with entrepreneurship let's make
sure the right answer to this question
isn't how do I go and find a partner
who's a business mind to team up with me
as an artist I can sell way more
paintings of India's than India can
because it's just what I'm great at you
know and that's without me really
knowing and truly as much as we adore
each other I don't fully know your
entrepreneurial sales abilities but I
just know mine are better because mine
are better than all of yours and so just
to what I feel and so that to me is the
answer to your question my friend and
obviously I gave that answer because I
want to provide one of things I think
I'm hitting a roll on in this golden era
is I'm starting to understand how to
answer the question at hand and then in
instead of picking answering the
question at hand or making it broad if
you've been paying attention as my own
self critique which is why I think we
have momentum I'm finding a cadence
right now how to answer the question and
at the same time broaden it to make more
sense and so the real story behind
everything I just said kids is hey don't
force yourself into things that are not
maybe naturally they are it's okay to
have a business partner a teammate an
employee you don't need a partner maybe
you hire someone to be the sales person
so super important because just like how
do I become X is a very dangerous game
especially if you just aren't capable
really truly not capable of ever being X
or just being a 2 out of a 10 index at X
where you better off spending 4 years to
become a 2 instead of a 0 when what you
could have done is gone from an 8 to a
12 and the thing that you're actually
great at time is valuable my friends
time is valuable
thanks I do think should head not City
Rock your positive reinforcement a bear
we're bringing some real marketing
beasts here here's my question for Gary
Gary which do you care about more
interacting with people who are your
fans who love you or interacting with
people who don't like you who are haters
where do you spend most of your time ah
Jay this is such a man Jay is such a
smart guy
and actually you know what J you may
think this is a insult Jay's a nicer guy
than he is smart and so I'm just a good
dude um J I think that um I think that
there's some interesting dynamics this
question I would tell you me 2006 until
2013 I would have answered the haters I
love the challenge you know me I love
the climb I love the challenge of
converting I also very much believe I'm
a good dude so many people didn't think
I was on their first impact because they
thought I had too much ego or I cursed
those would be the two things that most
turn people off when they're first
interacting with me many of you felt
that about me as a matter of fact leave
that in the comments if you were one of
them
you know as somebody who you know the
cursing really was standoffish or this
guy thinks he's the greatest of all time
it's been interesting if you watch
people that are commenting over the last
couple episodes especially in school
danira you'll see a lot of people
talking about you know how humble you
are and I laugh because I know so many
people would see that and be like what
you know you start getting to see the
layers as they go over time that's why I
always say I'm gonna win in the course
of a marathon so I really really was all
about the haters all the negative
reviews on this I went you know the
first hundred bad replied to and engaged
with and then something switched and
then I said you know what I'm
disproportionately spending my time on
the converted versus all these wonderful
people that are giving me these nice
accolades and comments and so many of
you know especially in Facebook because
I've been everybody that's been sharing
these episodes and then commenting I've
been jumping in randomly and saying
thank you because I'm so thankful
somebody decided to share this that by
the way that's a subtle cue to have
every single person who's watching this
right now share it on Facebook you know
everybody that's sharing it and getting
their ought friends to see this and
bringing me new audience it's an
incredible that's incredible versus
somebody saying your douchebag like I
need to reward that behavior because
they get happy with the engagement too
so I think I'm at a much better balance
I would even say that I'm probably 80%
the positive 20% the negative but but
I'm still very committed it's just maybe
because knock on wood the new show is a
format that is leaning to more people
liking me that you know the keynotes are
so brash the one-off rants are so Brown
- that if that's the first impact but
the show has you know a different tone
to it that allows more people I'm far
more consumable if the first thing that
you ever saw was this show versus you
know especially depending on the first
question I still got that in me but so I
would say both I think both matter
tremendously I'm so disappointed in my
contemporaries and friends who disregard
and just label anybody that disagrees
with them a hater I actually fully
understand why people disagree with me I
have very narrow views as a matter of
fact that are completely predicated on
where I think the markets going which
are not very clear to everybody else
I've got nothing for my confidence
confidence for days with like four Z's
right I've got confidence four days I
communicate in a certain style it's very
East Coast
it's Jersey in the house like I
understand like I hate Patriot fans
[ __ ] hate you guys
you know I get that that's not feels
nice if you're like watching this and
like a picture of Rambo go away when it
Gary hates me weird you know like I've
got my dynamics but what it all really
comes down to is everybody matters and I
have enormous empathy to why people
disagree or more might be put off by me
in the beginning and I think that they
absolutely deserve my attention just as
much as somebody who says I'm the
greatest of all time I like all people
whether they agree with me or not
whether they think I'm a dick or not
it's just all very understandable for me
and I also feel extremely a piece and to
wear this all nets out in our
relationship that's it cool another good
show
in mark yacht Kim's office it's like the
lawyer office look at all this like
weird stuff oh this way sorry boys
weird stuff Yacht Ken's got look at all
this like look at this guy's like New
York laws you know so like so what you
can does is like a rudder no you can't
do that it's all very very interesting
stuff that yet can gets to do here I
don't even know how to put it back a
question of the day who in your family
is a lawyer friends and family network
put their name down
tag them even in facebook so I can say
hey you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them